so the Ukraine war was all about money
after all
see BlackRock just struck a deal with
Ukraine's president the goal the
Reconstruction of Ukraine how very Noble
but here's the thing BlackRock is not in
the charity business no they got to 10
trillion dollars in money under
management by being as coldly calculated
as possible when they invest money they
expect to see a return so for BlackRock
rebuilding Ukraine is nothing but a
great investment opportunity and the
Reconstruction is not going to be cheap
right now it would cost hundreds of
billions of dollars to rebuild the
country if the war ended today if the
war lasts a few more months or years
rebuilding Ukraine will cost more than
one trillion dollars and now BlackRock
is in the prime position to take full
advantage of that click the link in the
pinned comment to watch the full video